It's funny when acting is, uh, like people really take it so seriously,
like Christian bale, just losing weight and chopping his,
and he's doing a new role was chopping his head off.
Did you know that he's playing sleepy hollow and he's legitimately Shoppe
chopping his head off. Uh,
and then he's doing another role where he's just his head. So,
and then that'll be his last role.
They're going to use the head chopped off for another he's shooting two movies
at once. Oh man.
When Christian bale flipped out. Oh, how about this dude?
When Christian bale flipped out. Oh, wow. We never talked about this.
Did we good for you when he does that?
Good for you. So whatever he is flip out on Terminator.
Let me tell you something about this dude.
The Christian bale flip out I'm on Christian bow side. Everyone's like, wow.
What an. that dude.
The lighting guy was with the light when he was acting good.
This is what happened. I don't know if you've heard it.
Here we go. Bruce is dissociated.
I want you off the set me prick. No,
don't just be sorry.
Think for one second that the are you
doing dude?
It's so I, and the guys being so nice about it. He's like,
I'm sorry, Christian. I'm sorry.
Don't just be sorry. Think about what you're doing.
So Scottish, but whatever. And, uh, are you professional or not?
Oh, I went for the juggler.
Are you professional or not? Yes, I am. The guy is so nice. He's so nice.
He sounds like a lady.
Do I walk around and rip that? No, shut the up.
I like, I started to cut them off. He just used that anger. No, shut the up.
Do I walk around? But I know. Shut the up.
You got to let a guy go. When the guy's off the ground like that,
you just got to wait for him to land. You don't say anything.
You start eating crackers for real. If anyone ever gets mad that mad at me,
I carry, you know, I carry around gummy bears. Just for that.
Just in case anyone gets me mad. Gay gets that mad at me. I just, I have a, um,
um, I take out a lawn chair.
I go crap and I wipe it out and I sit down and I opened my gummy bears that I
have been saving. And I just, wait, are you a professional?
And I'm eating Oh, a red one
because you can't do you can't be like, well, no, y'all hold up a second.
It doesn't work. I'm eating gummy bears.
No, no. Don't shut me up.
I'm not going to walk around and rip your lights down.
Wow. I mean, I'm not going.
To walk around and rip your lights down.
Obviously not, you know, but maybe he's making up.
We're at a point in the middle of a scene then why the are you walking right
through? Ah, like this in the background? What the is it with you?
What don't you understand?
He's right.
You got any idea about, Hey, it's distracting.
Worst sentence of all time. But still with them. I'm in dude. If I was there,
if I was Sam Worthington or whatever, cause this is on the Terminator movie,
I would have been Sam. I would have been behind him like, wow. Yeah, dude.
He's right. You know,
do you have any idea about how distracting Sam Worthington?
If you tried to draw Sam Worthington, you wouldn't know what to do.
He's so famous, but Wu Izzy, you know,
you'd be like, what is this nose do is he's just kind of regular, right?
But he's in the biggest movies of all time.
Then make a movie called Jesus Christ and he'll play Jesus Christ.
Having somebody walking up behind Bryce in the middle of the scene.
Give me a answer. What don't you get about it?
I was looking at the light.
Oh, good for you. And the guy goes,
I was looking at the light. Oh, good for you.
Oh wow. So patronizing patronize, patronize.
It never known how to looking at the light.
Oh, good for you. And how was it
good for you and how was it?
Oh, wow. I can't wait if I let's see, what would I say? Well,
I was looking for the like, Oh, good for you. How was it? I'd be like, you know,
it was fine, man. I, uh, I didn't, I didn't mean to get in, in the scene. He,
as he eats gummy bears.
I hope he was good because it's useless now. Isn't it.
Nice.
Shake, man. You're amateur. Wow.
This is the thing though. With actors, it's like,
he's doing a scene that's really intense.
Obviously robots are trying to destroy the world and he's using that intensity
and then a lighting guy does that.
And then the dude Christian bale is just like using that intensity and people
are like, what a dude. He's not, he's just acting, man.
I'm going to play for real I'll dude,
I'll be playing my Japanese guy or whatever,
or the in a movie or a Christian or a Christian, a, a
British dude. And then somebody will move a light and I'll just, I would do.
Oh, you really think you get to move a law.
And I'll be like, well, Chris is a Dick, but why is he British? When he's Dick?
Like all he was playing, he was, it was that movie with Sherlock Holmes.
Um, cool. My computer's not working. That sounds great.
Look, G you got something to say to this prick. Wow.
Well somebody should be stopped.
G dude. Miuccia you got something to say to this prick? He says,
I didn't see it happen. Oh dude. Now you know where G stands, dude. All right.
Okay. Okay. Nobody went to his bro Christian bale.
I would have been right there, dude. The jerky comedian, just.
Watching and keeping an eye on him. Fair enough.
Just second time that he doesn't give a about what is going on in front of the
camera, dude. All right. I'm trying to do a scene here and I'm going,
why the is Shane walking in there?
I'm trying to do a scene and I'm saying, what the is Shane walking in there?
What is he doing there? Do you understand? My mind is not in the scene.
If you're doing that.
Yeah.
Stay off the set, man. Wow. sake. This is so funny. Yeah.
Stay off the set man.
Just so after the fit, just, you know what, man,
stay off the set, man. Just got real, got down to brass tacks. You know?
No, I don't care. I'm acting. Let's go again.
Nice. Not take a minute. Let's go again. And it's so funny when you.
Get that heated, there's nothing you can do. Like he's like, Oh, let's go again.
And the guy says, well, we can take a minute. And he says,
let's not take a minute. Like you can't suggest anything.
You, he, the people could have been like, do you want a blow job?
We have that Emily rata to Chelsea. No, I'm a guy. I'm a guy,
a guys. I'd be like, okay, well we got Tyson Beckford then. And he'll. Nah,
I just went back to comes again.
Like you can't win.
And like to not have you walking in.
Can I have Tom put this on please?
Tom Joe.
You're unbelievable, man. You're unfucking believable and stop.
It's the best number of times you're strolling the round in the background.
I never had a DP behave like.
Wow.
Uh, you don't understand what it's like working with actors.
That's what that is. That's what that is, man. I'm telling her, is it dude?
Where is this? I'm not asking. I'm telling the way dude.
And he wouldn't have done that. Otherwise.
Stop it, dude. I got them. Hate Mac computers, man. Where the is it? Here we go.
Got it. Got it. got it. When he said something and he's just like,
eh, what does he say, I missed it. And now I've got to go back. God it.
You understand what it's like working with actors.
Well, don't understand what it's like working with actors.
You don't understand the, I know there's no video of it,
but I wa I hope you went like that. You went like this.
You don't understand, you know how it is working with actors.
Uh, you don't understand what it's like working with actors.
That's what that is. That's what that is, man. I'm telling you,
I'm not asking. I'm telling you, you wouldn't have done that otherwise.
Yeah.
I want to kick your, you know, shut up for a second.
Oh, he went after him doing the kick your. I was like, Whoa, come on,
come on. Wow, dude,
what if he just got leveled? What if the dude just went, Oh man,
another thing you could do is this. If a guy starts talking like that,
if you're on gummy bears, you can just go like this.
I bet that would what?
Okay.
Oh, I would do that. I got to do that either.
The gummy bears saying you don't have gummy bears. Do that anyway, dude.
It's funny, dude.
I'm so hot right now. I scream and I sweat.
The stand.
I don't work with, you don't folk it understand, uh, is working with actors,
right?
No, that's what it is. Good for. You.